buddy hello hello okay give me a sec i forgot to save my sound settings for silk song so um i do that real quick before we put it to sleeping dog sound settings i was like snip snap i always snapshot um all my sound settings if i'm doing it on playthroughs just so just so i don't have to be like what guys sound check sound check guys i forgot sound check okay sleeping all right what Sleeping Dogs,
okay, 12, 11.7.
All right, hello, everyone.
Hello, hello.
Today, we're going to, we're going back to Sleeping Dogs today.
But before I do, okay, wait, I want to listen to that.
Bram, over and over again while, over and over again while we're talking.
But, uh, did you guys see the new Mega Evolution for, uh, Pikachu 2.0?
No, Doki, it's for right...
No, no, you know...
You can see how badly they wanted to actually make a Pikachu mega evolution.
But because I assume like all mega evolution has to be like the final form of the Pokemon.
So...
So they're like, okay, we'll have to make right shoe.
But we'll make them look as close as possible to Pikachu.
yeah they literally just just turned rachu into pikachu two point and it's i'm sorry but it's just it's so weird it just looks so fucking weird okay for those who didn't see it's like legally distinct pikachu i'm like just make pikachu make it break the rule make pikachu like the exception like at that point don't force this on a rachu i it could have looked um know it just and then they make them x and y but like i will like i don't know it's like okay i understand because like they did that for like you know the mu2 and charizard but like charizard x and y was so it's so subtle like the the design elements to make charizard to represent x and y is so fucking subtle like because like it's like all the flames are crossed so it's like an x and then the y comes from the charizard y's wings because it's shaped like a y um but then like Pikachu is like we're gonna tell sorry right to mega evil look okay I'm gonna show you guys I need to give you guys a visual before I I know it's much more
subtle I I didn't even realize was meant to represent, like, I didn't even realize Charizard Mega Evolution were meant to represent X and Y until I saw, literally the day I saw Pikachu X, Mega Evolution, sorry, literally the day I saw Ritue Mega Evolution,
I was like, oh, wait, Charizard was supposed to be X and Y, so that's when I realized, that's how long it took me to realize that.
So it was very subtle to me, but then, like, No, this is like, actually, like, like, they, they, they, like, smash it to your face.
Like, do you get it, guys?
Do you understand?
Look, Ritual is an X.
Look!
So, so this is, this is Ritual Mega Evolution X and Y.
And, okay, so my gripes about, do you understand it, kids?
But like, because like, it's, on Charizard, it's much more subtle, but like, on Ritu, it's really like, okay, we're gonna put, like, I don't know, we're just gonna stick two of his ears on, like, two of his tails onto his ears, and then, and that would look like an X.
And then, for Y, what if Ritu has two tails?
Whoa!
Oh, wait, no, that's X.
Sorry, but for X, what if Ritu has two tails?
Whoa!
Oh my god!
Awesome!
But like, like, I don't know.
It's just, they literally, it's like Pikachu trying to cosplay of Ezraichu, but he bought the cosplay at, at five and below or some shit at the dollar store at Dollarama.
And it's just so yellow.
It's so, it's just, it's just so weird.
like, I look at Ritue X and I think it's Pikachu, not Ritue.
I just, I just, I just think it's just, it's Pikachu with bigger ears.
Um, yeah, Pikachu from Timo.
I, uh, oh yeah, no, I saw the, I also saw the Mega Evolution for, um, Green Ninja, Del Fox and the other one.
Uh, we all, know grass pokemon do not have any of our respect um but uh uh but it's just i don't know i think the oh and also the what's the other one the megalomar or whatever uh the water poke the water squid lady also got a megalitian and they're like guys look she's shaped like an m we're learning our I feel like it's like Sesame Pokemon Sesame Street right now.
It's like, hey everybody, do you know the leather M?
But no, I just thought it was it was a bit disappointing to see the mega evolutions for for Pikachu 2.0 because I feel like but like the artwork of them looks really good like the two artwork actually looks okay like it it salvages whatever the fuck the 3d is but the the okay wait 2d 2d mega evolution but like the 3d screenshots are i don't know the 3d renders just there's just something it just looks so off i think it's the colors the 3d render of the cut the 3d render of the colors for right shoe mega evolution is just so off uh 2d mega evolution right i almost say pikachu again i i can't help it it just it just looks like pikachu like i there's no i cannot defend this it's just it's just pikachu how do i defend this like but this is what the this is what the 2D artwork.
The 2D artwork looks fine.
It actually like salvages it a little bit because like I think it's the yellow.
The yellow is just too bright on the 3D render and then I guess I don't have to look at as fucking stupid as whatever the fuck the ears are on the other one too.
I'm sorry but like also like what the fuck is that?
Like what like what is okay Like, what the fuck is wrong with his ears?
Like, does he just have four ears?
Like, what is that?
I don't understand.
Are they just another pair of ears?
Like, what is this?
What is this?
I need to know.
What the fuck is this part?
Is it hair?
Or are they like...
Is it like an appendage?
Is it just...
Is it made of skin?
horns what the fuck is that but anyway that's i just really wanted to show you guys uh why does he have pikachu's face wait what does right shoe look like right shoe 3d render also i just noticed that's literally just pikachu's face i just noticed that okay right shoe right shoe pokemon x where's this 3d render it just gives me 2d It just gets in 2D.
What does he look like in 3D?
I need to know.
Because like 3D and 2D just looks really...
It just...
Yeah, no, he does.
Wait, that's literally Pikachu's face.
That doesn't even...
That's not even right to his face.
Like, they barely even changed the model.
Patriot S2.
They give it a super chat.
Thank you.
There are zero Kilo's Megas and XY.
One in Ruby Sapphire Remix and three in ZA.
But those three are seasonal.
ranked online rewards for season one two and three they hate pokemon friends so much thank you for the super chat thank you thank you wait you're right like wait oh yeah i heard about that so apparently to obtain the mega evolution um for the uh for greninja del fox and the other one uh you have to play online rank and it's per season So they're actually like,
I won't say paywalled you, but it's grind to win, basically, to obtain the mega evolution of the Kalo's, yeah, of the Kalo's starters.
So you can't even like get it for free.
I mean, technically you can get it for free.
Oh, is it paid?
Oh, it's technically, oh yeah, it's technically paywalled because you have to pay for online services.
I almost forgot about that.
uh a solid snake thank you the super chat thank you thank you who is that pokemon it's pikachu no it's right so yeah so like you can't even obtain it like you know you can't just like mega evolve um a random del fox you actually you you actually have to like participate in online mega evolutions are not for casuals it's all they are reserved for gamers only um but other than that uh i just really wanted to talk about because i i literally saw the mega evolution of right i'm just like the fuck is i don't know i'm just i just i just feel like right true deserves better you know as because like you can't even evolve right you like the normal way you gotta like Who the fuck would buy a Thunderstone for Pikachu?
Like, everyone will give that to Eevee.
Like, no.
Why waste a precious Thunderstone on Pikachu when you can just do...
When you can just give that to Eevee?
I...
Yeah, you're like the one person out of a hundred...
Not even a hundred.
That's, like, way too much.
500 players in pokemon they're true
but that's really the only thing i really want to say today um also another thing i have a problem and i've relapsed into uh a rank addiction on marble rivals again um it is a problem because yesterday i was like i'm going to be productive right after i feel right after my silk song stream and then I then I proceed to spend um I think like six hours on I think no no that's too much okay at four hours I would say four I started at like what seven p.m.
eight nine ten eleven twelve oh no never mind maybe it was never mind six hours it was I was like no that's too much and that counted in my head I was like what time did I stop play and I stopped to play stop playing rivals I was might be an accurate estimate to how much.
So I've accidentally relapsed into my rivals, not just rivals, sorry, I rank addiction again.
So today I'm going to try and be productive and not maybe play like one or two games of my rivals and that's it.
That's it.
So it is very unfortunate and my condolences to myself.
it's bad because i'm actually sort of a little behind work right now um so today i am going to lock in on my backlog and to-do list today uh and maybe just play one or two games maybe just one or two games uh anyway today we're gonna play sleeping dogs i don't know how long i'm gonna play today um i do want to still keep short streams just because like i said i'm trying to um make sure this week to this week is basically like voice recovery week so um that's why i haven't been um streaming a lot a lot of doing long streams this week um so i might just do like two to three hours today and then next week we'll be back to regular hours um anyway let's go play sleeping dogs maybe one more game 12 matches in zekro thank you for the super chat thank you thank you Sing in the Super Chat.
Thank you.
Hope we get enough Sleeping Dog streams that we get from Beijing with love or out of the dark in the title.
Sing in the Super Chat.
Thank you.
Alright, I forgot the controls again.
Oh yeah, I forgot I was Mukon.
I'm also a Mukon.
I was like, who's this a monkey?
I just forgot the combat controls.
I know how to run.
A is always running.
Go, Mukon.
Go.
um go to oh wait i was supposed to go back to sleep jk let's go back home i didn't realize i was supposed to sleep what happens if i let how do i what happens how do i don't keep what are you trying to do don't worry about i'm trying to remember the controls oh i think i'm not allowed to do by uh i mean i'm not allowed to do whatever the whatever the thing is i wanted to do um when i'm back home uh leave the aunties alone anyway sleep time this guy wants in he's gonna have to show me some blood on his hands you show your true colors tonight you already
oh my gosh i'm having flashbacks right now
okay that's fine just gotta repress my memory you know cycle press the cycle through okay uncle pull drug bust okay there's a drug bust here i might as well do the drug bust one i gotta up my police cred wait where's the drug bust cop job cop job where is it all i see are the the fuck is uncle po oh it's over here oh my god club bam bam that's it i know i need to go to it wait i didn't see it where's the blue oh wait is it this one oh it is okay this one's actually closer so we're gonna do the drug bus okay all these cop jobs so many cop jobs only one monkey all right let's grab our car what kind of car do i even have right now all right we're gonna make sure that they don't know i'm a cop
don't never know
oh shit
don't worry i'll grab them if i see i have the perfect car for it wait is it that one Is that the car?
I don't even know what those cars look like.
Is it this one?
Oh, it is!
Boom!
That's right!
Wee woo, wee woo, the cops here!
How do I grab them again?
Oh, it's this button.
Okay.
Don't worry, I got this.
Oh, shit!
It's okay!
No, it's not!
Wait, that's fine.
Please, I'm one of you guys!
Look, I have a police car!
Okay, I may have rammed the wrong thing.
Oh, shit!
Arran!
Okay, nice.
Oh, wait, now I'm closer to...
Okay, give me a sec.
I'm trying to remember the controls, guys.
Oh, wait, no, not my cop car.
All right, so...
All right, this is reverse.
Wait, what happened?
Oh, no, the cop didn't see it.
That's good.
All right, I gotta go back to ramming.
I hope I think...
Is this still...
Is this still around?
I think I lost it.
So...
Don't worry, I'm here to stop the criminal.
Don't worry, I'm here.
Wait, where's the drug bust?
Oh.
Oh, I lost a drug mission.
What happened to it?
It just disappeared.
What happened to the drug mission?
I don't understand.
What did I do wrong?
Wait.
I don't understand.
How could I lose my cop mission?
I thought I was being a really good cop.
Like...
What could...
What did I do to lose my job?
I don't understand.
What did I do right?
I can't believe it.
Alright.
That's it.
Oh.
Who's he talking to?
Hello, man.
It's the chairman.
Dahl.
Dahlia?
I like how they say they didn't translate Dahlia, but that means just big boss.
That's literally what it meant, but they didn't even translate that.
The rest of you, wait here.
Don't do anything until you hear from me.
What's going on?
You are staying here like I told you, and you are shutting the fuck up.
Got it?
Yeah, boss.
course good let's go
that's right i'm more important than you and i just joined there like i don't like a week ago like i was literally i literally joined this group a week ago and i'm already more important than you that's looking right at least we kept seeing wildlife see that's how good at role playing i am in the triad i'm gonna bump uncle police cut Oh,
but that doesn't it's not fair, you know, right?
Then you know look what I built the night market all of no point really Wait, he owns the night market?
What was I supposed to do honey?
I mean what hang up just what you did look you can't back down from that asshole You and him got history, huh?
Holy shit.
Oh, you should just be like should actually be a business owner If he's able to fucking run the night market.
What the fuck is he doing doing this?
He could literally just He can literally scam people legally.
Just be a...
Wasn't that blue-collar worker?
Conroy, they're good guys.
But they're not going to be leaders.
I know Conroy can earn more money by scamming regular people in a legal way.
Literally, he could be a CEO of a...
Look, I have to Peggy and my mom, too.
This can be a rough business.
But one thing we got going for us is each other.
Run it.
I know people use that.
of a Forbes company.
But it's not fun if it's legal.
I mean, technically, it's like, it's basically legal, but like, sort of illegal, but with 20 more steps.
He just needs to move his money on offshore bank accounts.
That's where he gets the balls to come after me.
He has a lot of power.
Along with drugs, he's in the process.
Institution for even sells women across the border into the rest of Asia.
Holy shit like an industry Very sleazy But big money Winston we can't just walk in there not if it's it's technically legal If any if the CEO of a big company is not arrested.
It's legal
I'd rather see it coming, you know, you should be okay But if I get my ass shot Do not do anything stupid.
You hear me?
Oh, we got this.
Fuck off, Johnny.
Hey, Winston.
My leg's stage, oh, she.
Dog guys tells me you've been throwing your weight around.
What happened?
You guys used to be tight as shit.
Is he here?
Nah, he left a while ago.
Without a scratch.
Doesn't bode so well for the other parties involved.
have fun I think I will surely nothing bad is gonna happen to me right I'm like the guy that got invited to a costume like I'm like the performer to the birthday party I'm basically like Elsa and Spider-Man and some tea and you young man must be way that's me Winston has been a good friend to me I've tried to do right by him whoa you got Wukon as your bodyguard that's pretty fucking that's pretty fucking sweet bro that's hardcore used to be more common Winston says you're the one who made sure silwa was not arrested as me no it was Winston's idea he had to assert himself assert his position but he didn't want to inconvenience you in the process
did he now In any case, you did well.
I want to show you my gratitude.
Uncle Poe, there's really no need.
Don't argue with me.
Do you know Roland Ho?
He has a business collecting debts.
The other day, he told me that he could use some help.
It's quite lucrative, you know.
Tell him I sent you.
Winston won't mind in the slightest.
Will you?
Thank you, Uncle.
Winston, Winston, Winston.
Winston.
I know you were provoked.
Oh, he's getting a shakedown right now.
Oh, yeah.
I was like, why is his voice so familiar?
That's Poe's dad.
It's the bird guy.
I was about a thousand bucks I was going to be carrying you on a fucking body bag.
Uncle Poe must.
like you yeah i don't think he has an opinion on me either way all right i tell you what you get tired of spinning your wheels in the night market give me a call oh they're trying to poach me um i like to be offered uh 50 more than the market value uh for my job is very specialized if you want to poach me take the car across the street i don't know if you're trying to see what it's like to be in
that's a shitty ass car he's like getting that car to know what it's like to be I'm like bro this car doesn't even look that like where's my Roy Roy's so yeah where's my Ferrari
I like how they call it like how they're like this is a special car it has the word executive at the back you're right it's gonna be okay there's gonna be work to do a lot of work to stay I always am.
Oops.
I stopped by the restaurant when you're done there, okay?
Got it.
Alright, nice.
I stopped by.
What is this?
Meet with Roland.
Look, it's not my car.
I don't have to worry about the paint job.
Hey, Roland Ho?
Who's asking?
Me.
Ah, why?
You got friends in high places, my boy.
I hear you and Winston have been making trouble with Dog Eyes.
Dog Eyes has been asking for trouble.
I remember when I was like you.
Always looking for a fight.
Ready to kill anyone who so much as look at me sideways.
Here's a tip for you, kid.
Don't take on a boss in your own triad.
Unless you know for a fact someone else is gonna back you.
p5 just sitting on the couch casually in the open in Hong Kong of all places thanks for the advice old timer so uh when can we get to work okay big man what tyler ding joe petzi wing bad luck at mashong you'll need this it's a bb cut oh my god that reminded me of the story of how like some kid Was,
oh yeah, let me, it's, let me carry it openly in the streets of Hong Kong, too.
Oh, it's MP7, yeah.
It reminded me of this article I saw of this kid in the UK that was cosplaying as Resident Evil, as one of the Resident Evil cops, I think.
And then he got, like, he got arrested.
He actually got like jumped on by like five police officers because they thought he was a The gun was loaded Post seems to have a handle on who's causing the trouble Look, I gotta go, Jackie Gotta see a lady about some money I was like holy shit And they like and then they showed the cost then I was like And like I don't know if like the gun is because like apparently if it's a bb look i'm making my it's a shortcut uh apparently like bb okay please i'm oh no oh no no okay they don't know i'll just say i'll just say i parked my car and then some guy stole it and did all that you understand huh shit that's a lot of muscle what the fuck is going on i don't even have a car yeah and then the thing is it's a oh sorry if it's a if it's a bb gun it should have they would have an orange tip but the thing is uh like and and the and the gun did have an orange tip
so people were like do the cops not see the orange oh my god i got an suv for a chase for a car chase
I'll get I'll get you I'll Don't worry I'll get you Oh yeah I think I didn't get them guys It's very exactly Oh nice I got Nice They realized They realized that What the fuck?
How do I They realized What the fuck are my bullets made of Titanium Like...
Sorry.
Oh, this.
What was I...
And he realized that the SUV was not car chase friendly.
Jesus.
Like, like, mini, mini mutes or some shit?
Action movie bullets.
Each bullet is its own grenade.
It's fine.
Oh, wait.
I didn't kill them yet.
There we go.
Alright, almost there.
Nice.
Oh my god, there's more cars!
What the fuck?
How is this car still that?
Okay, it's not my fault.
There's another car beside that car.
Okay, this car has to be made of like the head...
This car must be made of tank materials.
Because what the fuck was that car built out of?
Okay.
Where is...
Are you driving?
There we go.
Ow.
Oh no, I think I have to steal someone's car soon.
My car's not doing so well.
My car's starting to smoke.
Hold and press A.
Oh yeah, the jumping.
on top or some shit okay i gotta get closer they're not dead guys don't worry we don't know that we don't know if they're alive or dead all right i'm almost there come on
i'm already there what what are you serious are you are you serious are you so please how did he get
I gave him a little boost.
I gave them a little shortcut.
How the fuck do I do this part?
Okay, there we go.
Holy shit, that was so complicated.
Press...
It was so complicated, guys.
I had to press one button.
What do you mean?
You old guy like rolling home money.
If you're running away, you did something.
you're sorry i care if you have the money i don't i'm sorry yeah give me my money stop saying sorry and develop making me develop a human connection to you
what the fuck she just drove away oh it said innocent it didn't say innocent killed guys it said innocent a damage you got the money no innocent got a boo-boo all right and i have to do bring it back here as soon as you can oh no oh nice i still have my i still have half a cop start guys i'm still legally a cop i got worried i thought he was gonna ram into me all right here you go so this way we're following traffic laws right now by going on the right side of the road this is still though technically i'm still technically i'm still on the road okay we gotta stash this car yeah
yay see i still have my half a cop star technically did my job
i did it i'm such a good cop
close enough a pass a pass this is a pass fail class we're not technically graded shed finally where the hell have you been look i have any idea what's going on what happened at the warehouse do you ever actually read my reports you have to write reports while all i have to do is read the game man man they're calling it a massacre if it ever came out that the police were involved we're dead i have homework you at least you at leads could have turned seawall over to us it would have helped our case and we'd put the entire operation at risk that's what does pendrew say you know he's not your handle way i am well then fucking handle it raymond i do write reports for everything i'm doing whatever it takes you remember that you want to result and you can't get them sitting behind a desk nose in a rulebook with a stick up your ass i'm under cover that breaks my immersion what needs to be done no terminate this operation exactly it's not gangster work if you have paperwork pendrew may like to
take chances I don't and you are dangerous fine I can push him off before you go back building right now the plug go ahead and tell pendrew that I just met the chairman of the Sun on ye the chairman then this mission will still go on well this foot soldier has just been marked for promotion because I made sure Suwa got out safely it'll be in my report and Maybe this time you'll actually read it.
No one will know if he accidentally tripped on top of this rooftop because this meeting was technically off the records.
And then I can be undercover forever.
Oh shit, I got a new house in Hong Kong Central.
Oh my god, soon I get to live in Hong Kong Island.
Let's fucking go.
Okay.
Intel reports reports illegal fighting on the secret island I got you an invite Faria leaves from central Oh my god Look at my shower It's so bougie That there's a bathtub in my shower Like holy shit I'm oh my god I'm making it in the big world now I'm moving up in the world Oh my god this Okay I might need a cop Oh I can use the toy Okay nice all right guys i hydrated a lot okay do i flush okay nice all right i might need to get a plumber for this toilet i was gonna say this toilet is bigger than my ass like like i'm scared i'm going to fall through this toilet all right gotta wash your hands after you pee guys remember to wash your hands all right maybe not like instantly put it touch my hands on my face like nice oh shit I got guys welcome to my crib I don't have a oh that's my laptop where I write my report where's my TV do I not have a do I not have a TV how will I watch my TV be didn't even do I have a fridge wait which one's the door okay okay I have a this is my gaming PC Um,
I can only run, uh, Overwatch with, uh, with 30 frames.
Uh, but look, after I get this promotion, I will finally be able to run Overwatch with 60 frames.
Whoa, imagine that.
That's right.
Retiring to a big boy and a bit with his big job.
What have I?
Oh my god, I got Fanta.
Oh, nice.
Increased damage after...
Okay.
He's like, someone will pick that up.
Alright, let's go.
When did I get this house?
I feel like we, like, jumped.
The time skipped, and I didn't even realize.
Wait, why don't you guys want to keep talking?
Guys.
I am in your tax bracket!
what they're like oh the poor is here let's leave excuse me i live here i'm literally in your tax bracket
all right let's see where do we go oh my god this place is a yeah no this is this place is like sparking some memories right now I am in the bougie part of Hong Kong.
Yeah, I'm definitely in the bougie part.
Where's it?
Bride to be.
Available.
Oh, wait.
Okay, we have to go.
What is this?
Water Street.
Where's the mission where they're going to take me out into the island?
Oh, here.
Oh wait, that's another drug bust.
Yeah, Wukon in his heavenly apartment.
I actually don't know where the next mission is.
Is it actually here?
Ride to be?
Alright, gotta get in my car.
Crazy rich monkey.
Is that not the island?
Don't do the island yet?
What else can I do?
Is that that or this?
what this is the water street one it doesn't say it yeah it says water street or wait is water street oh oh the island is the else okay so i should do the i should do this then i should do bride of b i
would like to get my undercover car real quick there we go no one will know i work for the cops all right how do i turn on the radio again, guys.
Sorry, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Hey, Toki.
I got your nendroid.
Yes, it's freaking gorgeous.
Thank you.
Thank you for the super chat.
I'm so happy that the nendroids arrived safely.
I'm so happy to see all the photos of everybody taking pictures of the nendroids.
I saw someone also got their Garfield nendroid and they basically, like, made them hold hands.
I can Oh, that's a maoshi.
Oh, we got rammed at.
Wait.
We finished rammed at him?
Where's, wait, where did he go?
Okay, there he is.
Get over here.
Get over here!
I didn't finish the job!
That's right!
Oh, wait, wait.
There's a copper side.
It's gonna act cool.
We got act cool.
Nothing bad is happening.
Don't worry.
Don't worry, bro.
I got this.
Don't worry.
I got, oh.
that motorcycle oh no okay give me a sec let me don't worry bro i got this case i'm investigating the car crash bro don't worry
i'll just he doesn't know i'll slowly push him away from the cop don't worry he doesn't know don't worry i'm slowly pushing the car back
Don't worry.
It's slowly moving out of the ring.
Gently does it.
It's slowly getting out of the cop ring.
Oh my god.
Is it because there's another car behind him?
It's because there's another car behind him.
Okay.
He's turning.
That's good.
it more oh my god give me a sec slow and steady does it come on keep going keep going it's almost out of the ring this is working out great guys don't worry we're almost there we just gotta get it out of the ring we just gotta get it out of the ring guys Okay,
I think it's out.
Let's see.
Oh my god, it has to be, like, right here.
Oh, shit!
The AI!
Every Buddha itself!
They even put it!
Everyone was like, the glitch fixed itself.
They're like, are we in the matrix?
No, we're not.
Let's go on with our day.
All right.
Jesus, how many times do I have to ram this car?
There we go.
Alright, now do I...
Oh, wait, get back in that truck?
Oh.
What do I do?
I did it.
What do I do now?
What do I do with this car?
Know what to do.
Oh get in that truck.
Oh
All right, but I can't get in the truck Oh supposed to hijack.
Oh my god.
I wasn't there.
I wasn't here.
I wasn't at the scene.
I wasn't I wasn't it was not me It was I'm too far from the truck.
What did I do?
Oh my god, give me a second no wait he can do that.
Oh, I didn't realize that That's right, I'm getting...
Uno reversal!
Oh no, oh no, oh no!
I didn't realize!
I can get a wreck!
That's it.
Get out of here.
That's fucking wreck.
Oh wait, fast travel.
No, plan, guys.
Now it's like seven massages!
Cops can also get arrested, Joki.
They'll never expect me.
I'm in an SUV.
They'll just think I'm a mom of seven.
Petting the soccer practice.
Great job, Joki.
Joki, you and the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I don't want to change the radio again.
I don't remember.
Guys, it was a speedrun tech.
It took me closer to the mission.
Hey, hey, hey, come here, come here, come here.
Hey, don't fall in here.
I'm sorry.
Damn.
Peggy?
Who's Peggy?
Yeah, he mentioned it.
Congratulations.
no problem at all mrs chew no problem i could take her for a ride and then i could take peggy for my fifth girlfriend
that's right i'm ready to meet my fifth girlfriend oh my god thanks for driving me around wait and she's settled for Winston I still have to pick the color I want he won't believe how much work it is to get ready for a wedding we've been planning for eight months now and there's still so much to be done I'm sure it better be perfect isn't wouldn't she be suspicious she'll be like how the fuck did Winston afford all the oh wait but she's just like as long as I get my dream wedding no oh
my your life is why it'd be good you have to have Someone you can be soft with, too, eh?
It's very important.
If you're hard all the time, one day you'll forget how to be soft.
What the fuck, Adam?
What was that?
If you're hard all the time, you won't know what it's like to be soft.
Uh, she's a handful, but, you know, her bark is worse than her bite.
That I know.
How about her me, Clever?
hard go hard or go home she used to scare me but then one day i was having a problem unless okay but if it's but then go see a doctor if it gets too long and mrs chew gave him a big lecture in front of the whole gang i thought she might use that cleaver on him ever since then winston's been an absolute doll and even though she still yells a lot i know her if it lasts longer than then uh
I mean, you know, I used to have a thing for blondes, too, and that drove her crazy.
Not enough if I went out with a Chinese-American girl, but...
But a whitey!
Well, if it's good to know she was loyal to her people.
No, she's loyal to her prejudices more like...
Congratulations!
No whiteies!
Damn, mom!
Whoa!
and
my mom and my mom was right look what happened with me and Amanda I was just I was just Asian to her she broke my heart I'm here to finalize the details of my mom was right yes yes I'm just the driver I'm just gonna change back and then we done actually there is one other thing black orchids this probably sounds silly but it was my mother's favorite flower and now that she's gone oh yeah she's dead I'd love to have a black orchid centerpiece I'm afraid that's impossible there are none to be found in Hong Kong really well I thought they had some down at the garden temple just shipped them over well yes but they're not for sale the other day the ceo of old boy trading one-in-one for his daughter he told him they offered temple 100 000 holy shit it's incredible no you mean money can't solve all problems a couple seats together for the rest of their lives oh well way come on wait i thought a black orchid was for your mom now it's just like superstitious bullshit like pick a struggle man
because you want to stay with Winston forever.
Also, give me a sec.
I gotta...
Give me a sec.
I gotta get my extra HP.
I'll get back in the car.
You can wait five seconds.
I waited for you at that shop for two hours.
Actually, no.
Longer two hours.
I waited in that bridal shop for like maybe five hours while you're trying out dresses.
You can wait in the car for five seconds while I'm doing like some blessings or whatever a temple will impress me it's our wedding oh is there a jay oh wait there's a jay sad okay wait for 10 more seconds it's her special day it's not even her special day this is not even her wedding day so emergency shop is called somebody is stealing our wedding cake must be that asshole dog i stopped the robbery little boy excuse me no it was me my sister Growing up in old prosperity,
she, you know, she started down a particular road and couldn't get off of it.
All right, we got to steal a wedding.
We got to steal back a wedding cake, apparently.
Change who she hung out with, you know?
Did it?
Yeah, for a while.
It's fine.
I'm a good driver.
I can make it.
Winston mentioned that she passed away.
How did it...
She's not even the wedding day.
Wedding cakes?
No, it's good to remember.
Our wedding cakes usually made, like, on the day.
day just so i'll stay fresh how the are they stealing a cake that doesn't is that shouldn't exist yet it's not oh i thought wedding cakes are usually or not on on like usually they are on the day aren't they yeah
i know most the cake is not edible because it's just cardboard hey isn't that a van from the wedding cake company hang on what are you doing yeah the guy the guy had the wrong address Winston asked me to make sure the cake is delivered he's so thoughtful yeah it's so thoughtful you don't catch that bend you won't have your special cake at your wedding what faster faster go faster oh maybe it's like oh yeah maybe it's like the cardboard part of the cake is being stolen it's not even edible they'll just remake the cardboard it's fine
Holy shit, that is a fast ass fucking bad.
What fucking engine did I put in there?
Like a fucking, what do you call it?
The Formula One race car engine?
A NASCAR engine?
Why is it so fast?
Get out there and get him.
My car, my car.
Here, here, take the wheel.
Careful, don't hurt my cake.
Oh yeah.
Just regular things you do to get your cake back.
Never late to deliver.
If you, this is the whole, like, if you get your pizza cake under, if you get your cake over 30 minutes, you get it for free.
Oh my god, if I, maybe if I stop shimmying back and forth.
Oh, I'm supposed to climb up.
I didn't realize I was supposed to climb up, like, climb to the driver's seat.
I thought that's automatic.
so thoughtful wait slow down i was just like what is what is he doing but then in the end it's what am i doing i truly thought that like um it was automatic you know where i just have to stay there and then he'll just climb up by himself the ai will take a hold of him but where's acting hero I'm just busting it down on top of the van
He's not pulling over you're a gangster do something get out there and get him.
Wait, how does he know wait?
So she she knows that Winston's Winston's a gangster.
I thought she was lying.
I thought he lied to her about it She says don't hurt my cake as we casually just ran over a lady there Alright, there you go.
I'm still heading over.
Oh my god, don't worry.
I got you.
Wait, that was a...
That was a woman in there.
I thought it was a gang member.
Wait, maybe she was delivering someone else's cake.
That seemed like a regular citizen.
That did not seem like a triad lady.
I think we...
No, we didn't come.
commit a crime.
No.
Winston said that they were stealing their cake, and I believe Winston.
Wow, that's great.
I'll take it right to him.
Uncapped.
Thank you for the welcome to tomato farm.
Welcome, welcome.
All done.
Thank you, Wei.
Thank you.
Alright.
I'll drive Peggy to the temple and start robbing.
I guess we'll rob the temple.
We're going to the temple, aren't we?
I knew you'd understand.
Yeah, but she was like, she was like dressed like a regular citizen.
Not anymore.
Well, you're wrong way.
You have family.
You have us.
Thanks.
Yeah!
I know Winston's work can be rough, but it makes us a family too.
I'm surprised she like willingly married into like a triad.
I guess like, you know, she just closed her eyes and just be like, just be like, ooh, new Louis Vuitton bag.
Thanks, but I'm not looking for anything serious right now.
I wouldn't want it to reflect poorly on you.
I feel like the amount of stress and paranoia you get from being a wife of a triad gang member.
Because usually, don't they, like, you just lie to their girlfriends and be like, no, the reason why I work late nights is because, like, I'm just working a regular 9-5 job at the company.
Okay.
Wait here.
I'll be right back.
Get a robe?
Oh, cool.
Nice.
We're gonna perform sacrilegious deeds right now.
Surely I'll go to heaven with this.
Last walk past the monks to pick up the orchid.
How would they know?
How?
How would they know with my arms filled with triad tattoos?
How would they know?
When it...
When energy flows among flowers, we are all everywhere.
How do you do, fellow monks?
It's so true.
I love flowers too.
One simple trick for cheaper weddings.
Fevery.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You'll never know.
You don't belong here.
What is belonging, brother, when we're all part of the same cosmos?
So true, besties.
He's like, oh, you're so true.
So true.
What happens if I...
Oh, wait.
I can't believe he snitched on me!
It was...
I tripped.
I tripped and my hand accidentally knocked him on his face.
I can't believe it.
What a narc.
Fucking narc.
That wasn't very cool of you, brother.
Oh, wait, I already grabbed the guy.
I tripped.
Don't belong here.
What is belonging, brother, when we're all part of the same cosmos?
Okay.
I didn't even beat him up!
My foot got caught on a pebble, and then I fell down, and my hand just accidentally brushed his face.
Oh, shit, money.
Yay.
What's this?
How do I do this?
Oh, it's...
Oh, my God.
What's the code?
Oh, it's 14?
14?
Am I timed?
I'm not timed for this.
I just have to slowly turn it up.
Alright, nice.
Oh, it was 23.
Wait, what the fuck?
Why didn't it go across?
There we go.
Oh!
I had to hold it in for a while.
That's why.
Alright, nice.
I got...
I got knockoff clothes.
I'm new here.
I'm a new... I'm a new intern.
part of a single great organism that never dies.
It's like, good enough.
Good enough.
Foxbowl, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Thanks for elapsing, making my days better.
I'm a little late, but my birthday was two days ago.
So can I get a happy birthday from my Kamiyoshi?
Of course you can.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Foxbowl.
Nice.
Wait, fight your way.
Oh, shit.
Your shell is soccering me.
Oh, my God.
It's okay.
I can just run away.
I bravely ran away.
Oh, wait.
Look, there's a shrine.
Give me a sec.
Let me do this shrine real quick.
I think I...
Wait, what's that?
Oh, yeah.
I think I lost him, guys.
I just ran so fast.
Who would have thought?
These monks got hands!
Wow, the best...
The best defense I've ever seen, guys.
Wow.
The greatest defense I've ever seen from a bunch of monks.
I can't believe it!
How did he do it?
They ran on the right side.
We were not prepared for that.
They are monks, not guys.
Oh, wait.
Thank you so much.
How can I say no?
They learned to fight, not run.
Do you have any wisdoms closing the backs?
I don't think these robes are going to make the right impression.
What do you think about this?
Our plan foiled.
Who could have expected him to run to the right?
Oh, I almost, I almost pressed the round button in the drive.
Uh, Winston is not gonna like this.
He's gonna like it because this was free.
We basically gave him a cheaper wedding.
Anything for a bargain.
A good deal is a good deal.
Alright.
Oops.
No, my police car.
All right, as long as I don't damage life, uh, I don't damage property, it'll be fine.
The police didn't expect a U-turn!
That's right!
The newest tech in police chases U-turns!
wait oh no oh no oh no he expected the U-turn oh my god this this alleyway was so tight holy shit this has to be like our best the best police driver ever bro this guy should like change careers right now
No, stop!
Holy shit, he's still behind me!
He's not giving up!
But that's...
Oh my god, he expected a U-turn.
But does he expect a U-turn of a U-turn?
He did, guys.
He's still right behind me.
Formula!
Oh yeah, that's right.
And then backwards!
And then forwards!
right get double juke's get uno reversal of an uno reversal thank you way thank you that's right did he expect an O-turn he may have expected a U-turn but what about an O-turn Peggy I know I know women's intuition it's It's the same with Winston.
He talks tough, but underneath he's a very caring man.
That's why I love him.
Thanks.
Oh, that guy fucking murdered like 10 guys, like in a week.
But he's so caring.
No, you don't understand.
He didn't murder me.
I hate that argument, though.
You know how like people say friends are really toxic or bad people?
But they're like, yeah, but he's not toxic towards me.
And I'm just like, bro, that person.
Bro, that person.
done so much bad shit and they're like yeah but he treats me well i hate that and you i know people like that too thanks for being so helpful way i really appreciate it of course sometimes this wedding thing stresses me out there's so much to get right and you only get one try don't worry peggy it's gonna be perfect oh it's so nice to find someone you can really rely on on i can see why winston likes you whoa okay i just realized what she was wearing
damn i can see why winston likes you too oh shit i have a no mock drip what happened to my drip no wait how much do i have to save to have the swat uniform i'm so sad They took away everything I love, including my drip.
No, there's a regular massage parlor in front of me.
I'm dripless now.
I spent so much money, too.
I'm going to return to Jace statue real quick.
No, I need, like, 300k or some shit.
To buy the police uniform.
So they'll never know I'm actually a cop.
the skies they'll be like wow there's no way he's a cop because why would he make it that obvious
yeah i'm hiding in plain sight
i found one of your statues tiger oh the tiger ever think about going back to the states i didn't work the first time why would it again the past goes with you wherever you go so you will confront the past rather than from it.
Damn straight.
I wonder is the past something we can defeat or is it something we simply come to terms with?
You just gotta move on.
What would you like to learn?
Alright I want to learn.
What is this?
Oh nice!
I can finally break someone's arm!
Okay how do I do it?
Crack one two and then oh my god I break it Oh, wait, no, I already messed it up.
All right.
All right, now that I broke your leg, it's time to break your arm, too.
Oh, oops.
Sorry.
Okay, now that I gave you a concussion, it's time to break your arm.
There we go.
Oh!
You paid for this.
That's the worst part.
Now it's time for your left arm.
He paid to get his arm broken.
All right, now I broke your arms in four places.
You're welcome.
What an honor.
Again?
All right.
Okay, Seifu.
Again?
Okay.
When does this end?
When will it end?
Oh, I think it's bugged.
I'm pretty sure.
Oh, yeah, it's bugged.
The first hit doesn't register.
Oh, okay, I'll bring you into this, too.
That's why you're in.
Okay, you're not bugged.
The other guy was bugged.
That's right.
Oh, my God.
Okay, yeah, this is bugged.
I'll just do it to this guy.
Okay.
Oh, now it works.
Okay, nice.
There we go.
We did it.
Now it's your turn.
That's right.
Oops.
Now it's your turn.
Oh.
Gotta make some ramen real quick.
Let me break the noodles.
Yeah.
He's like, please.
Not again.
Please.
Oh, man.
The arm crunch, too, afterwards.
It's crazy.
He's like, wait, wait, wait, wait.
It's like, not me!
Yeah?
What?
Holy shit!
Oh my god, now he's shouting soccering right now.
Like slapping, yeah, snap a glow stick real quick.
I'm making spaghetti.
Bro's got combos.
Nice.
I gained arm break.
learn how to break an arm.
We break the pasta.
I never break it, broke pasta.
I don't know, I just, I don't like, I don't like short noodles.
It's just, it's just weird, you know?
For me, it's just, it's just the taste.
I know it doesn't change the taste, but like, eating like, shorter noodles just, it's just so fucking weird.
It just, the texture is wrong.
Where am I supposed, where's my next mission?
Oh, Wait, it's just Water Street?
Wait, my only mission is Water Street.
Why is there another tempo?
Sheldon Showdown?
Oh my god!
Wait, I gotta go.
I'm gonna break some monks' arms.
Because, like, you're so used to the longer noodle, so when you start snurping and then, like, it's, like, stopping at 50%.
It's so unsatisfying Now that I learned how to break arms it's time.
There's no way they recognize me, right?
There's no way they recognize me as the guy that stole from them I know I would like to enter your I like to enter your tournament
Oh, shit Oops, I fucked up That's right Oh my god, that's right got your name Oh, shit.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
Wait.
These mugs are ungrabbable.
Oh, my God.
They're ungrabbable.
How do I grab something I can't grab?
That's crazy.
Okay, not.
Oh, my God.
They're actually ungrabbable.
They're so good.
Oh, my God.
Okay, I just do counters.
Just do counters.
I'm just going to counter.
There's no reason.
There's no reason to punch back.
That's right.
I'm playing defense now.
I'm going all on D.
Get down!
Get out of here!
I can't believe it.
I learned all about breaking arms and I can't even use it.
Wait, is there more?
Oh shit, there's more.
Oh wait, nice.
oh gonna pop my glow stick real quick guys oh shit okay i should have to just counter because i don't have a lot of hp i only have half hp oh and it's raining too that's when you know we're in a movie right now that's right whoa oh shit get out of here oh my god and the and the Yellow tone,
too?
No, Rain makes it cinematic.
That's right.
One more.
Come on.
Okay, you're weak now, right?
You're not.
Nice.
All right.
There is three more.
Oh, there's just chill in there.
They're like, who's at that?
They're just having a smoke break.
all right i'm ready i'm ready full d come on do your shot it's very nice that you go one by one i love it just like the movies one by one it must have been the wind
nice i'm like hercules
fighter in the world if anyone says otherwise it's fake news they use special effects people can't fly if hercules can't fly no one else can he's the greatest warrior in the world just like my hero oh wait wait can i grab you i still can't grab you There we go.
Oh, wait.
You're still alive.
Nice.
Oh, wait.
Now you're gone.
I'm still missing one more.
Who's still alive?
Oh, shit.
What the?
Is this 9 out of 7?
8?
20?
What?
Guys, I don't think it's a tournament anymore.
I think I'm actually doing an invasion.
Like, I don't think this is a...
40!
Guys!
I think they're trying to defend her home, guys.
I don't think this is a tournament anymore.
I'm raiding the temple.
Wait, back.
Wah, wah!
Where is this at?
I'm here.
Wait.
He's scared.
That's right.
I play silk song Okay, I know which one Which one can be grappable They're the ones that keep going Whoa!
Okay, watch this guy This guy will be grappable, watch Oh wait, he's not It's the ones that are scared of me
Alright My pile The monk pile The monk is going It's a tournament, guys They said I signed up for a tournament Legally, I can do this.
I swear, I'm not doing a raid on your temple.
It's like they're actually trying to defend their home right now.
I'm like, hey, guys, this is a tournament, right?
Where's my prize?
It's the monk pit.
Yeah, I'm creating my own mosh pit, guys.
And they're like, sorry, Doki.
Doki, it was actually the tournament was supposed to be the temple from across the street.
You think I'm gonna go to heaven?
You think a temple will accept my spirit blessing?
Imagine if I got the wrong address.
Who the pile you go?
That's right.
Hostile down.
I like how we're calling them hostiles.
He was like, he came at me with his foot.
I had to defend myself, guys.
Their body parts are registered weapons.
Oh, dear.
This was all self-defense.
All 40 of these bodies.
I was defending myself.
up last one
i think this is a little too much for some flowers but what do i know um it wasn't for flowers it was for a tournament wait i didn't even win guys i didn't win money guys i i'm starting to believe that was not a
Where's my money reward?
I got a quote.
Yeah, I like raided the closet after I beat up 40 monks and be like, that's my reward for the day.
I was like, guys, look, I got my trophy as I raided their closet.
Let's see.
Do I do this?
People are saying this is a DLC mission.
There's no other missions, though.
Yeah, it's literally just Water Street.
Like, go to Water Street now.
That's right.
I showed them how to do the real Kung Fu.
Alright, we go this way.
Oh, Water Street is not the SD.
Okay, that's good to know.
I got confused.
Alright, we listened to this radio.
I pee.
I'll be right back.
I'll just...
Yeah, that's fine.
I'll be right back.
I need some bathroom.
Okay, let me double check something real quick, guys.
I'm not blocking traffic.
Look, my car jams.
It's not my fault.
All right, let's go do the waterway.
The waterway?
Water street.
Let's do water street now.
I feel like not even at 50% of this.
game for the story.
Does anyone know, like, where?
Am I even halfway?
Because it's like, if this is like, it's like Hong Kong GTA, I assume the story is, like, really long.
Classic curves never go out of style.
Wait, is this a race?
I don't want to do a race.
Wait, do I have to race?
Oh, I'm at 40%?
Oh, I didn't even realize I did that much progress.
Get away!
She was in the way, guys!
She was...
I have the right away, chat.
I...
Oh, wait.
There's a speed race there.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
I have property damage for this.
We're in a race and we care about property?
Look, why she's standing in the middle of the road it's not my fault
that was her own fault for standing in the middle of the road i was just trying to drive this is a race it's all about winning or losing
no i drove straight guys she walked into my path you all saw that She walked into my road.
I was driving straight.
It was straight, guys.
Yeah, I should win this race.
Victory at all costs.
Nice.
That's right.
Reputation.
Go up.
I show these cops how to drive.
Alright.
Oh, wait.
It's the wedding.
Oh, it's the wedding now.
Oh, my God.
The wedding is today?
Wait.
I gotta go get dressed for a special day.
Where's my house?
Where do I live?
Okay.
Parking lot.
Clothing.
Where do I live?
Does anyone know where my house is?
Oh, there's my house.
There it is.
Alright.
The house is so...
Okay, wait, actually...
I don't want to drive a little bit lowly over there.
I'm going to hire a taxi.
Alright.
Did it even take me there?
oh my god the controller sensitivity is so ass okay there it is okay nice it can actually take me
there nice like give me your car make me pay 310 Hong Kong dollars I know I like to park this car what are you doing what the fuck you can just steal this car back oh no he just wanted to beat me up Oh, he doesn't know who he's fighting.
Oh, shit.
Wait, I'm trying to remember how to grab.
Give me a sec.
There you go.
That's right.
Let me make a phone call real quick.
I just gotta make a phone call real quick.
It's like, what you get?
Now it's my car.
He's like, oh, he's dead.
I don't have to worry anymore.
How do I park this car?
I just bought this car.
How do I... How do I park it?
Hello?
Take my car.
No, this is my car.
Alright, here.
Take the keys.
Go park it somewhere nice.
Alright, I gotta go change real quick.
It's... It's my boy's wedding.
I gotta look nice.
Alright, off to the closet I go.
uh custom outfits yes wait where is it oh there it is okay hi roller phase four required oh my god i can be i can actually be a bruce lee that's the perfect unit this is a perfect outfit to go to that way
that this is the perfect outfit don't never know how would they know i don't understand not i'm just i'm cosplaying guys i'm going to an anime convention i'm cosplaying a resident evil cop wait can i steal a bus oh my god they have even have the double decker bus wait i can't steal a bus why can't i oh i can't Get out!
It's the police!
The perfect car for the wedding.
They'll never know I'm an undercover cop.
My disguise is perfect.
Now, police get out.
This is my wedding gift.
To Winston and Peggy.
I bring them a bus.
I brought the party bus.
I brought the party bus, guys.
I don't...
No!
Tuxedo!
This is technically a tuxedo.
It's all black.
And this is technically a tuxedo, guys.
Bye-bye.
Hey, man.
I'm stuck in traffic.
I'll get there as soon as possible.
Don't worry.
It's still time.
Don't start without me.
Alright, drive to the banquet hall.
I got the...
Don't worry, I got the party bus.
Winston's gonna love this wedding gift, guys.
Don't worry, we're almost there.
Look, it's very hard to turn.
This car is fucking huge!
There's so many black...
What the fuck?
Did you just see him levitate?
Holy shit!
They got a magician at this wedding.
I did it, don't worry.
Anything for you, Winton.
Thanks, Way.
You both must be very happy.
The best day of your life.
So they say.
You know what?
They're right.
If you say so.
Oh, man, he's looking forward to the honeymoon.
I'm happy to be here.
It's nice to see someone who wants to be a good family man.
not enough of that nowadays i mean it tend to not live long enough for that thank you almost as lovely as your mother and mom oh and this is true i expect the food to be wait wait i got a case of the chairman's favorite wine in my car i forgot to bring it in oh he's ready to suck up to him i'm gonna make sure he gets inside okay yeah sure thing you gotta enjoy your day okay where are I'm going.
I'm going.
Just bring it inside.
I'm going inside.
Oh yeah, he has so much Riz.
Am I gonna get robbed?
Shit.
Oh my god, what happened?
Is it a godfather situation?
Jack, you there?
What happened?
Did you see that?
Oh my god, who got shot?
There's no way we're getting in through here.
I'll find a way inside.
Oh my god, someone got shot!
How do I...
Okay, parkour!
Don't worry!
I learned parkour in America, it's very popular over there.
What's going on?
Not the le- Not the le-
Oh my god, it's a red wedding!
Stay down, bitch!
What the fuck did she do?
take out that catering staff all right no my white suit to the wall you go
oh my god please i'm trying to take him to the wall guys that's right oh shit you think that's gonna scare me now they've done it this wall needs a shade of red oh wait
oh wait you're wearing red that's a perfect color for this wall is there anything else i could do there oh my god wait wait a minute what does this do oh wait oh i can't even there's no one liner for that there there's there's guys do you think YouTube's gonna demonetize me I looked at it for two I looked at it again I couldn't help but look at it guys I guess he's not dead he's just hanging up he's just hanging
there's anything else oh Santa said you've been a naughty boy oh shit he has a knife Welcome to London!
Ho, ho, ho!
He's hanging in there, man.
Hang in there, kitty.
That's right.
Did you get cold for Christmas?
Holy shit.
He's just saying...
I'm sorry.
No, he's just saying...
I don't even think I can look at him.
I'm worried that I actually...
YouTube's gonna...
The YouTube AI is gonna...
Like, take the stream down if I look at it for too long.
I'm just...
Whoa.
There you go.
You do not look at it.
I like how there's, like, screaming in the background.
I'm just kidding.
Phew.
Phew, phew.
Okay, I actually have to use gun now.
Oh, that is not cover, sir.
There we go.
I actually have to use guns.
I'm gonna shoot you in the bar.
That's right, no kids for you.
Ball shot.
Did someone call up in you?
Thank you for the super chat.
Solid, thank you.
I made a severe laugh subjunct.
It said a chandelier.
I was like, whoa, what am I going to do with a chandelier?
What's that?
Peggy?
Oh, God.
Peggy.
Wait, is Peggy dead?
Out of here.
She doesn't deserve this.
Wait, is she alive?
Guys, I...
It's okay.
It's just a little blood loss.
it's okay she's just she is just a little blood loss and she's fainted guys that's not her blood
whoops wait i lost that's all my gun okay i'm just
right now it's time for the ball shot all right let's grab this gun there you go I'm curious.
That's the craziest shit you can do when someone is aiming at you.
Wait, but like, I gotta make sure.
Man, these are... Man, did we not tip the catering staff?
Alright.
Now, we gotta double tap just in case they turn in the zombies, you know?
I just don't want... I just gotta make sure!
What if they turn in the zombies?
I'm securing the kill.
Call the rest of the boys!
I need them here now!
Holy shit, these catering staff's hardcore.
Okay, this gun fucking sucks.
Not gonna lie.
I should have stayed with the pistol.
Alright, nice.
Hostile down.
See, they're the bad guys.
It says Hostile down.
There you go.
Ready?
Alright, it's a black...
Are the white shirts part of my team?
Is it... Oh wait, they are.
I was gonna say, is this black shirts versus white shirts?
It's like skins versus shirts.
We're in PE right now.
Wait, who shot me?
Oh my god, it's like all the...
Oh, of course you peek your head the moment I look on the other side.
There we go.
I think that's it, right?
No, there's still one more guy over there.
There we go.
Go to the stairs.
Where the fuck's the stairs?
Oh, this way.
Okay, I still have a lot of bullets.
Nice.
Wait, what's this gun?
Oh, it's just regular.
Wait, where's the white shirt?
Wait, are they all dead?
Bro, what the fuck?
Wait, oh my god, you guys...
Why didn't you take cover?
Clear all the...
Where did we... Did we hire this kid?
you step at Timu?
at that, what was that app where you can hire handyman to do, like, you can hire people to do, like, random tasks for you?
I forgot what it's called.
It's like, it's like Uber, but for people.
No, not Fiverr.
There's like an, there's like a, task rabbit.
Yeah.
I felt like, did we hire these guys from task rabbit?
And then we're like, and we accidentally gave them, like, one star, so they brought out their guns.
Oh.
It's okay, he's a lot.
Sorry, buddy.
I just had to make sure there were zero witnesses, guys.
Uncle Poe, are you okay?
Can you walk?
What's going on?
What happened to Winston?
Okay, come on.
We gotta get you out of here.
I like how Winston was like save Peggy and then way was like I gotta help the old man
Don't worry
Wait, okay, this is I when I have uncle Paul I can't take cover
He is my cup how do I can't even put him in front of me is he my cover i am i'm technically i'm just as meat shields apparently
how are you getting shot there is no way you're getting shot when i'm literally behind that oh wait i'm not aiming anymore i'm just fucking shooting
all right don't worry we gotta take you to don't worry if we run faster if You might lose your blood faster, but we'll also get there faster.
That's the risk I'm gonna take.
Usually you're not supposed to run when someone's bleeding out because it'll, like, cause them to lose their blood faster.
Oh, my God, I got reload.
I ain't...
I'm 1 HP.
Okay, I gotta make sure.
Alright, here we go.
bring him across there oh my god he can't shoot me I'm in the water oh my god how did he live that I shot him in the balls oops sorry uncle Poe sorry he's burning and losing blood I shot his his Don't worry, I got you!
I got you, Uncle Poe!
My uncle, he's hurt.
We need a doctor.
Now!
What is this?
What's going on here?
My boy, maybe you'll want to leave before our friends, the police.
Yeah, I catarized his wounds, guys.
That's why my HP went up.
And if anything happens to him, I'm holding you personally responsible.
Oh, thank God.
I'll be clear.
Okay, okay.
I did it!
Look at that.
I'm gaming.
I was gonna say, how is my cop score higher than my try-ass score?
I feel like, if anything, I'm gonna fail to count.
Okay, we need that.
We're doing a lot of counterings.
That's crazy.
Okay.
Where have you been?
Stuck in traffic.
It's Hong Kong.
That's so true.
Chiff took the MTR.
Is it easy for me?
I know you've been through a lot, boy.
More than we have any right to ask.
Now the wedding.
It was a massacre, Raymond.
A massacre.
Winston was a red pole.
Sure.
But his wife, a fucking gun down his wife on her wedding day.
We knew you would become personally attached to her.
It's inevitable.
Not a snitch guy.
I don't work for the cops.
How dare they say that?
No, it's not.
You're a cop.
So which one of you guys is under cover?
I'll pull you out right now.
Pull me out.
Your job was to get close to Winston.
Now, that's not much of a strategy.
Get close to you.
Open your eyes, Raymond.
I am Winston.
That's true.
I'm gone.
I'll be taking his place.
Because they both died.
I report to him now.
You want the red pulse?
I'm one of them.
That's what worries me, Wei.
You're one of them.
You want to give up the best undercover HK PD
I'm the best they've ever had.
I'm the best they've ever had, guys.
They'll never know.
Guys, I'm the best they've ever had.
They've never caught me.
They'll never catch me.
Oh, more PTSD.
oh no wait why am I living back here in my shit room I got I literally got a promotion the craziest part is like this shit home has a TV not the one in central alright let's leave how did we downgrade I got promoted I thought a promotion means I get a better house
Wait, we gotta grab The usual Alright Hot shot lead, a meat ace Okay Got me ace now Wait, I gotta get some ramen first I got some noodles Some one ton noodles, one ton meat Oh, it's herbal tea I mean, that's the same thing
Tiku yum thank you that's my go-to yum ta tea i always get i don't know what it is because that's just what my parents always get but i always order tiku yum when i'm at yum ta all right i don't know what's in it
all right here we go it just sounds good oh it's okay we're not on a mission so i can do all that
Oh, wait, it's been a while.
Oh my god, I can't believe it's been two hours since I got my last massage.
Hello.
I would...
Hello, I'm about to get my seven stamps for another free massage.
I'm almost there.
I'm almost gonna complete my stamp rally, guys.
I'm so stressed out.
After that wedding, yeah, massage is very needed.
Nice.
Alright, let's go.
We gotta stay in peak conditions.
That's right, we can't have it all bottled up inside, guys.
We gotta be relaxed for this.
Wait, what?
There was a drug bust?
I was not paying attention.
Oh, shit.
I drove away from a drug bust.
I didn't even know.
Are they still there doing the drugs?
Oh, they're gone now.
Oopsie.
I guess they're gonna still keep doing whatever they were doing.
Not anymore, I guess.
Where is it?
Hot shot lead.
Okay, it's this way.
Look I was busy, okay?
How do I reverse?
I was busy!
I had a very important meeting at that massage parlor This is where I conduct most of my business meetings All right, here you go
Look they're they're police cones and I'm the police That's how I get that that is based they put those cones up to make sure that the police can use that part of the road See this is why you got wear helmets when you're on a motorcycle guys motorcycles are even more dangerous than driving a car and i'm gonna prove you why
so remember to wear a helmet hanta thank you for the rage thank you thank you all right it's this way no he didn't wear he didn't wear a helmet guys that's why that happened to him Thanks for the PSA, Koki.
I would wear my helmet from now on.
What?
Trace Ace's phone.
Oh, I have to go to the center.
I was like, where do I have to go?
Oh, shit.
That's cool.
Where is the center, though?
Like, here?
Here?
Guys, I'm trying to get to the center, guys.
I think it's like Oh, it's here I'm almost there He was interrupting police business Alright
Okay, I have to turn this way And then Is it here?
Where the fuck is Oh, now I'm like Look He was in the way for police business It's whatever That means necessary.
Is it here?
Because it's taking me so long to trace this stupid-ass call.
It might just be here.
That has to be the center now.
Is that not the- there we go.
Stand the strongest signal.
Okay, central.
What?
Hello?
you okay find the one common to what what does that mean oh get to the crash before ace girlfriend dies am i timed oh no she'll be fine i'm not timed so now i can follow it's okay i can follow traffic laws she'll be fine she has plenty of blood in her body oh i am timed Top left.
I didn't look top left.
I looked everywhere, but top left.
Okay, that's how fast her blood is flowing out.
I didn't realize her help.
Oh my god, what happened?
Did she fucking got stabbed?
How did she lose that much out of nowhere?
What the fuck happened?
Did she just randomly got stabbed on the side of the road?
Like...
She's averaging right now, Toki.
Oh my god!
Something!
Okay, I'm here.
I'm here.
Where is she?
Investigate the crash.
Okay.
Holy shit, how did she get down here?
Oh my god, you're okay.
Who's he?
Ace?
Oh my god.
Were you wearing seatbelts?
See, this is why you should wear seatbelts too, guys.
This is her.
She didn't wear seatbelts.
You'll be alright.
You think he's okay?
He's fine, right?
Yeah, I think he's fine.
He's just hotboxing the car.
Always wear your seatbelts, guys.
Oh, photograph the car.
Alright, don't worry.
You might be dying, but I gotta take a photo.
There we go.
Calling Ting.
Yes, Inspector.
Hot shot kill days damn it way.
We were supposed to catch them in the act.
Yeah, well they acted too fast I have an eyewitness statement and all the evidence you need to get that you didn't call the ambulance or didn't just show up Don't bother.
I have a better idea.
I'll challenge him to a race and once we're in it.
I'll lead him right to you all right But wait, I want him alive.
Are they still there though see they're okay see?
What happens if I
Wait He's gotta return to his people
Oh my god Oh my god I gotta go I gotta go I thought he'd float I thought he Oh my god is he still Is he still there See, it's the easiest to go.
Guys, he returned to his people, guys.
He returned to one story.
I really need a man.
He is.
He sure is floating.
He's definitely floating now.
Let's see who rules the street.
Where are you hiding out?
You come, we watch.
Guys, look, nothing happened.
There was no paramedic.
See?
There was no body.
Guys.
Nothing happened.
I didn't...
I don't know what you're talking about.
Nothing happened.
Wait, this is a fast car.
This looks fast.
There's no body.
No body means no evidence.
He's one nothing washed away Yeah, yeah, if anything it was hot shot I can't believe not only did he ram somebody and ram a car into the ocean He also he also drowned a paramedic.
That's so fucked up sir.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you
Yeah, I can't kill someone if there's no body I
anyway also does this look like an outfit of a murderer look at that also
the car was in the ocean and a paramedic went out in the ocean to try to save them but it's just so sad he didn't make it guys he just didn't have the strength to swim that far it was so sad
Like he managed to save the woman and the car, but he was just not strong enough to save himself How unfortunate he got the car though he used all his strength to
That's my mom he tried with all his strength, but he used it all and get that car back onto land
Holy shit the paces of him yet oh my god he's his car is so fast someone shoot the tires i should have brought a gun i wonder if i could bring a gun and just start shooting his car
guys guys how do i change the radio i don't want to listen to this how the fuck do i change the radio oh my god this ai is
I feel like I'm in like...
I feel like I'm some like...
Oh, what's...
Oh my gosh, I'm trying to figure out like how to describe this feeling of this music.
Is it D-pad?
No, that's my phone.
That's my...
Oh, I actually paused.
Oh, it's the left.
Oh, I went the wrong way.
Do you guys think I can catch up to him?
This is a shortcut, right?
Oh, it is.
You're about to hear the awesome psychedelic from LFO, followed by Durbox, the dark dubstep track from Harmonic 313.
Wait, dubstep?
The big-time party vibe track, Parisian goldfish from Flying Lotus.
Oh.
Wait.
Ooh.
Oh, I went to Aberdeen?
Wait, this is Aberdeen?
I went to Aberdeen Center.
Okay, no, this is not a good dubstep.
This is not a good dubstep.
Oh my god, I disabled his car.
How the fuck do I disable this car?
Did I do it?
Come on!
All right, how do I disable it?
Do I just keep ramming it until he gets caught?
All right.
Is it disabled?
Do I have to like ram it?
That's it.
Oh, there we go.
I did it.
Oh, wait.
Can I not do it?
Where is his car?
Wait, did he flip back?
How the fuck did he flip his...
He lived that?
Bro, your car's on fire!
Your car is literally on fire, bro.
Like, get out.
Like, get out of the car.
His car is literally on fire.
We picked Tachana.
Little Punk never shuts up.
You should have seen the look on his face when we charged him with murder.
Nice.
20 years at least.
Nobody pays much.
Yeah, the three murders that he did.
The woman, the man, and the pyramid.
I can't believe it.
He murdered three people, guys.
Including the paramedic.
Got high right.
Or high roller.
Nice.
Got an upgrade.
That's so fucked up.
I can't believe he committed three murders.
Fucking.
That's absolutely crazy.
Miss Choose Revenge?
Let's do that one.
Wait, how is there two?
What's the other one?
Where's the new boss?
Okay.
Let's grab, let's help a mom get revenge.
The yellow missions are worth?
I don't even know what the yellow...
Oh, these?
What even are these?
ones the high speed no I don't want to race that sounds like a racing mission what are the yellow missions what
do they normally give what are they oh their favors
okay let's
we gotta relax now after we solve guys we solve the crime today guys we're heroes that paramedics family didn't die in vain sorry not the family the family can finally rest easy because we are heroes we solved a murder today what a hero look at us we caught the criminal now his family can rest easy
You gotta know They charged him with murder For three different murders
Alright This way Alright here we go
Hello Mrs. Chu Are you okay?
Mrs. Chu You like my Halloween costume?
Halloween's next month guys I I know it's no consolation But I gotta look at one of the gunmen from the wedding Now I will find him And I'll make him tell me who's responsible
I like how in the subtitles She repeated it one time but then sometimes like you bring him to me you bring him to me and she's like you bring him to me she says calmly yeah she wants blood blood Ricky this way way how you holding up I got a lot of not so good I need an outsider for a couple things you got Johnny rat face his number Johnny rat face Johnny rat face I mean yeah he's got rat face I know all about She's gonna make him dinner.
And he is the dinner.
Oh my god, I hate this one.
I hate this mission.
I mean this one where you have to like fucking find the center.
Like I don't fucking know where I barely know where I am at let alone the center.
Give us this way.
I got that part.
In here?
maybe yeah there you go trace call
hey is this uh is this johnny yeah um a friend sent me to you works with a lot of movie stars you know what i mean so so i got a problem he said you could help me i'm busy wait wait wait please look i trade diamonds down in central my partner took off with all our stock and by the time the cops look into it he'll be halfway to shanghai i'll never get them back diamonds huh all i need is someone to recover them i pay a large fee okay okay i don't I know his name is a large buck tooth show he lives at what do I do this Aberdeen Road but I think he may be at his girlfriend's apartment yeah yeah where's that she's that I'm so confused she's up on Marlboro it's a green building with a lot of I'm so confused what does this mean what does this mean I think there's an aid in it do you go look I'm very sorry sir here it is 818 he's not a tall man big buck teeth what does this mean He wears white shirts,
black shoes.
Oh!
Oh.
Fucking hell.
Look for one that it's in all.
Oh!
I'm so confused.
I don't understand the tracing part of this mission.
I was like, how do I know what color the trace?
Oops, wrong way.
Wait, it's this way.
It was like, look for what?
And I'm like, what?
What does he mean by that?
Guys, remember to wear your helmet.
It'll be just like him.
Oh.
One of them is in all.
They all look the same.
What makes it different?
Hey, is this Johnny?
Yeah.
A friend sent me to you.
Works with a lot of movies.
No, I just didn't understand.
Because they all look the same.
No, I got a problem.
He said you could help me.
i'm busy wait wait wait wait please look i trade diamonds down in central oh i'm so stupid oh they're all like down oh i get it
oh it's like the one that doesn't move yeah i was at the wrong side oops My car is really hard to control.
Wait, what?
Is it not over here?
Yeah, I was gonna say, why did it tell me to go somewhere else?
Hello.
Oh, you lovely, baby.
I promise.
Are you insane?
Think of all the money.
Oh, is this Johnny Ratface?
Oh, okay.
Yeah, now I know why he's called Johnny Ratface.
I'm not taking off my clothes for you or anyone else.
What about me?
Hey.
I work for the police.
I'm like, I'm undercover, girl.
Oh, wait.
Can I?
Oh, shit, I can't.
It's time.
Don't worry.
The one thing I know how to do.
Defense.
Holy shit.
Nutshot.
Get down.
I can't believe they don't.
Let me grapple anymore.
No fun.
But how about you?
Can I grapple you?
Oh, yeah, I can give me a sec Give me a sec looks like your car needs some repairs.
Oh Shit.
Oh my god.
Oh So I take out the trash
Oh my god ow my face my beautiful face Wait, you ready to swim with the fishes?
Oh wait.
He's like, oh my god, did you see that?
That's right.
Get over here.
That's right, don't never find your body!
That's right.
Oh shit, ow!
Hey, that's not cool.
Oh, no, that is not cool.
Okay, I gotta do a counter for this guy.
Alright.
Oh, fuck!
I was not expecting that.
I was waiting for...
Okay, not you.
I'm waiting for this guy.
Come on.
Get over here.
Alright, I need to get that fucking beam thing off of you.
Alright.
Are you serious?
Jesus!
Okay, that guy fucking...
It's so hard.
all right i just gotta break his arm i guess
no don't do it don't listen to your intrusive thoughts today i almost today i felt like i felt like a little okay so um am i at my apartment uh sometimes people there's like a little table there and they people would like leave their uber east order or like y'all say no witnesses they'll leave their like door dash order or like uber east order on this table and sometimes there's like food there that's been sitting there for like a couple of hours and when i take that out for a walk i'm like doki don't do it don't because it's just sitting there i was like it'd be so easy but i never do every day i don't do it so that makes me a good for not committing a crime.
Every day I think about it.
Say hello to the paramedic for me.
Oh, never mind.
I guess you're just gonna be here.
I'm fighting.
Alright, we gotta get rid of the knife though.
I'll get rid of the knife.
There's just too many people for me to grapple.
I'm such a saint, guys.
Doing the bare minimum.
I'm glad you still...
Look at me go.
I did the bare minimum and not stole food.
I'm such a saint.
Okay, that's enough now.
Alright, is there any...
Oh, there is.
It seems...
Oh, wait, nice.
It seems we have an electrical problem!
Alright, get over here.
We're gonna have to feed the fishes.
I'm glad you have self-restraint.
There we go.
Oh my god.
And the body washed away.
See?
I'm a good person.
Oh my god!
What?
Oh wait, that's not what I wanted.
There we go.
Give me a sec.
Alright.
What the f- I have to shoot him in the- I have to shoot him in the- I can't shoot him in the nuts.
It sucks.
Has to be- has to be- Whoa, what the fuck is that gun?
Has to be in the chest.
No fun.
There's no way you survives that
We are We're giving that we're giving the people what they want the ass How do you survive 20 bullets in the ass?
Hostile down
I think can you actually survive 20?
Okay if you just started firing at the ass like can you live through that?
Like it's just literally 20 bullets to the butt because it's just fat right it's just muscle and fat so as long as oh wait you can't and like and you don't bleed out
yeah yeah i'm just thinking like how many bullets in the ass can you take before like before it's too many bullets before your ass doesn't cushion anything anymore okay i gotta grab steal this gun real quick all right i don't know Probably, yeah, but it's like,
if it's like not a high caliber gun, and then you just keep like, like it stops before it hits the bone.
Or like it just hits the fat, you know?
Like, there you go.
There you go.
You're still alive?
Jesus.
Like a, yeah.
Definitely just one.
all right hostile down holy shit how many are there you never and it missed us five
there's so many rules through this it's like a little it's like a test you know it's like that oh yeah i told the story before but for those who never heard the story there was a guy on was it out i don't even remember Oh shit.
Oh shit.
He shot me in the head.
I got two.
There was a guy that was like, oh man.
Oh my god.
He was all over again.
Okay, I should not get distracted.
All right, we're gonna headshot for real.
No more butt shots.
Guys, no more butt shots.
I didn't realize.
It's like that guy that was like trying to build immunity on bullet shots and shot himself like every, he shot himself every
don't do that that's actually so fucking stupid he was micro he was literally trying to micro dose bullets yeah that that's like no i'm not joking that was legitimately a real thing there was a guy that tried to micro dose bullets and he was like he was like oh i couldn't i had to stop i hope someone else will continue my studies Holy fuck,
you're crazy.
That's actually crazy.
And he's like, these are my, this is my study and I have to stop because I found the limit.
He's like, I found my body's limit.
Which is crazy.
There we go.
All right, I got cover.
I'm actually aiming at their heads for real now.
I was like, I'm not dealing with that.
So anyways, so like on that topic, I wonder if you can like, I wonder how much your ass can take.
Because it's technically just muscle and fat.
Like there's no like, as long as you don't hit any important arteries.
There should be a...
Oh, shit.
See you later, motherfucker.
I'm gonna fucking... I'm coming over.
Guys, look, I have a helmet.
A hat is technically a helmet.
There we go.
Guys, everything I say is a joke, by the way.
Don't...
Like, I gotta try to micro-dose fucking bullets.
I gotta... That's a joke.
That's a joke, by the way.
It's just... It's just me...
being curious.
Just so people are wondering.
I do not, do not test this area out.
For legal reasons, for legal reasons.
It's just, it's just me being curious on how they can ask him be to stop a bullet.
Alright, there you go.
Wait, did I lose the car?
Wait, oh wait, why is it not red?
Oh now it's red
All right Man, I'm nearly right behind it.
Oh, there it is.
Oh, I have to hold a I keep forgetting.
Oh my god I almost jumped onto the wrong car.
Imagine if I did Yeah, I've got you now.
Get out Who are you?
What do you want?
Friend of mine wants to serve you some noodles.
What you crazy?
Look man, I got powerful friends.
Oh yeah, it's like that...
What was, is it Mythbuster?
Tell me their name.
So we can go see him right now.
I don't remember if it was Mythbuster that does it, but they would like create...
Fuck you, I'm not gonna tell you nothing.
They would create like jelly humans.
Well fuck him too!
Alright, this way.
Was it Mythbusters that would create jelly humans to test out like really fucked up theories?
Yeah, Ballistic Gummies.
If you get a BPL, will it save your life?
I asked the important questions in life.
Meet Mrs. Chu.
I know what I'm...
I don't know what this guy told you.
She said, She said, I don't know what you're talking about, you crazy old bitch.
She should cut each individual fingers.
Of course she's crazy.
She lost the son and the daughter.
Just please.
Oh!
Guys, I, I, I, She's prepping barbecue chicken, guys.
Barbecue roast duck, guys.
Guys, I think she was just making barbecue roast duck.
My favorite.
Guys, I also do not think those were fingers.
Bro, God turned into fried rice.
Oh, hey, the next mission is literally right next to me.
Nice.
Oh, shit.
Give me a sec.
Oh my god, that was like that was a smooth exit High important business to do Yes, it does my video save my life countless times Eddie thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you It was a very stressful day guys.
Oh I'm gonna say I can't it'll be crazy if my game Bunked out and I never get my massage
All right, let's go let's go meet that new boss Be crazy.
I broke the game because I wanted another massage I was like what are you saying?
Winston's gone right now.
We gotta stick to We just can't let the 18 can't get away with this makes you so sure it was 18k they'll never know i'm undercover guys you're too stupid even stupid jackie knows that you ever think maybe they were just trying to look like 18k look we've had a few skirmishes with them lately nothing major it doesn't make too stupid to know guys it's okay they can't read that's the best part they never learn how to read and who the fuck are you i'm here for mr lee i take it you've heard a big smiley he's another son if they asked i'd be you don't know the the new the new luxury brand polis um it's pronounced polis polis by polis oh mr lee that's an interesting proposition but i have a counter offer from mr lee i'd appreciate if you relay this back to him word for word can you do that you tell mr lee that his people stay of our territory and in return we'll let him live i don't think you'll find that offer to his life he's like boy i've been i've boy i've been in this business for 30
years you'll regret this i promised you that damn
get to my crew what the fuck is that gun Oh my god, I think she...
I did it, I'm a hero.
There we go.
Excuse me, I...
I'm like, how many times do I get shoot you in the nuts?
Damn, this gun is... whoa.
Holy shit!
I'm playing James Bond right now.
Okay, James Bond, that can't aim.
Apparently.
That's on a... James Bond on a roller.
Oh man, I should really stop tanking that.
Oh wait, I used up all my ammo.
Oh, I did not realize it was limited.
Give me a sec.
I got another pistol.
Don't worry, reload!
Are they all dead?
Where's the last guy?
Oh my god, more people.
Oh wait, that's my people.
I was gonna say, where are my people?
The war.
Whoa!
Oh, wait.
That's my guy.
That's...
Oh, wait.
He was a bad guy.
Never mind.
I thought...
The red didn't show up!
I thought he was the good guys!
Where is he?
Where are they all dead?
Oh, shit, no.
There we go.
Give me a sec.
We're okay.
There's no way there's friendly damage towards like the- Oh my god in front of- Holy shit, where are the cops?
I'd say with my palest uniform, my palest friend.
Oh shit, I wonder where.
Oh my god, this gun is crazy.
This is a fucking crazy, crazy shot.
There you go.
I only have, I have seven bullets, seven bullets to make this count.
Okay, it doesn't help it that it does two damage per shot.
Are you serious?
Okay, give me a sec.
I need to pick up a gun.
Okay.
Time out!
I have to pick up another gun!
There we go.
They're still... They're all dead.
Okay.
Okay, I thank God I'm not driving.
Don't worry, I've got you guys.
Okay, well, one of them's fucking nice.
Oh, shit.
Okay, that's...
sick that's actually sick i'm glad i don't have to drive though i just gotta look back but is he also part of it guys but are they are they also yeah they are i just gotta aim at the don't worry he's okay he jumped off at the right time i think another one pew pew pew pew pew pew and like Nobody call it cops?
There is a very active car chase going on in the back.
Don't worry, everything is fine.
Just an average day in Hong Kong, I guess.
They're like, I'm just trying to sleep.
Alright, nice.
They're like, don't worry, we already have a cop on the scene.
And it's actually me.
I'm like, I call in dispatches.
Like, don't worry, guys.
I got this.
No need to, no need to bring in more cops.
Holy shit.
That was all four of them in that car.
Oh my god.
They, like, have the entire economy of car chases right here.
There you go.
There's still more?
Oh my god, I got reloaded.
I don't know how I did not get any of the tires there.
There we go, we made it.
We're in central.
I swear, I think I, like, destroyed, like, 500 grand of cars.
Uh, that's our...
Thank you, my super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
explode I've shot so many tires that's right I'm coming for you stop I'm a cop oh shit wait don't worry I can catch up don't worry I'm going after you now I'm coming after you but How did he get there?
Oh, it's here.
Okay.
How did I say it?
Oh fuck.
Okay.
This is awkward because I don't know how he got up there Give me a sec I gotta figure out how did he oh my god Wait, how did he oh my god wait no come no no no wait, please for the love of God
Oh, it's the bed Oh my god, it's the bed he got He gone, God.
It's okay, it registered.
Oh, shit.
Ma'am, don't worry.
I got you.
Oh, wait.
I get to keep your purse.
Going to my purse now.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
I picked everything but the white mask.
That's right.
Oh, my God.
But what if?
What if I...
Wait, wait a minute.
Wait, I have an idea.
I just need to get a little closer.
It goes with...
Yeah, it matches my outfit, guys.
Yeah, they should have made the van yellow.
Exactly.
Okay, but what if, like...
No!
Jack!
The throw button!
I was gonna throw...
I forgot which one was the throw button.
No!
my purse i could have went into that fight with my purse are you done all right wait oh oh he doesn't let him that's right oh my god wait
that's right today is today is remodeling And I chose a nice red color
The wall strikes again Oh shit Wait what the fuck Why did my food He started buffering on screen
Oh shit Oh my god I was timing out to fix the food shit I was like what the oh please do not see me I'm worried I won't police by police by police whoa don't worry that's like don't you move
what I'm trying to get into that are you serious I'm praying I pressed why?
I pressed why?
Okay, there you go.
Who the fuck are you guys?
Change your tone, Shay.
Miss Yang?
I did not- I'm not driving the car.
My hands are actually off the controller.
I can't believe it.
AI hates AI.
valuation.
I will get to the point.
You must realize that you cannot stand against Big Smile Lee alone.
That's what everyone tells me.
Roland Ho said I'd need other bosses to support me.
Bro, it's in the back of the limousine.
How could it have been me?
I wasn't even in the scene of the crime.
Peace.
And I don't mind spilling a little blood to achieve it.
With Uncle Poe in the hospital, there's much uncertainty in the sun on Yi.
If he recovers, We will both be stable and strong.
But if he dies, the 18K presents a very real threat.
We cannot afford to appear weak.
We will need to elect a new chairman quickly.
You, for instance.
Ah, Big Smile Lee represents a step backwards for the sun on you.
Why continue to force girls into prostitution and pornography?
Wait, we do that?
With other, less archaic, more profitable ways for us to make money.
Yes, it's time to force the boys.
to the man equality am I right but it would be a wise even for me to stand against big smiley unaided which brings me to you now we both appear to have the same problem Wei Shen and the opportunity to benefit if we work together so it seems I have my own reasons for hating big smiley's operation I feel like that's not what she's trying to imply.
Damn.
Oh, I guess she's the new boss now.
Alright, new story.
Drugs, hookers, and boring.
What?
What is this story?
Some fucker named Naz is ripping me off at the top, Glamour.
Need your help.
read this report.
I'm curious what this report.
Okay.
Drugs, hookers, pornography.
And these are the pillars of the rising crime empire in Hong Kong is hardly surprising.
These tyrants have controlled the drug rackets and sex trade for more than a hundred years.
Holy shit.
Some speaking on a report that he has been paying, parlayed his cash flow into a prime position It is now heir apparent to Sun Yi, On Yi, and possibly Olive.
The filmmakers wanted in on the lucrative porn industry, and Lee had the best women.
In return, Lee got access to the multi-billion dollar industry.
A large sum of money moved from one shell corporation to the next.
Oh, shit.
He got in on the porn industry.
Wow.
I swear, I will say...
Whoever...
That's right.
The police give me their car!
I will say the genius who discovered streaming porn must be a millionaire.
Whoever that guy is is a goddamn millionaire right now.
Wall Street.
Oh wait.
Loose and cop job.
Or, no, not million, sorry, billionaire.
They have to be billionaires.
There's a movie about it?
Oh, yeah.
And if they pattern it, that is, like, the smartest thing they've ever done.
Imagine trademarking porn.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
You know what's even crazier?
I'm pretty sure it was pre-Netflix, too.
Now that I think about it, that had to be pre-Netflix.
I just realized.
The fact that we came up with bad idea before we came up with streaming TV shows and movies, like priorities, you know?
For actual priorities.
Was it pre-YouTube?
Oh my god, the fact that that's pre-YouTube?
Wait, you won't believe what those assholes did.
Those guys are top glamor.
The pioneer.
They brought them another load of watches.
They were supposed to give me 200,000 for them.
Instead, they give me this hunk of shit.
I don't even know how to ride this thing.
I have to push it here.
Calm down.
Give me the bike.
I'll get you your money.
What are you gonna do?
Same thing I always do.
I always do, Jackie.
What do we do?
Wait, what is?
I do a lot of stuff way.
You gotta be more specific.
Like, what do you mean?
Same thing like I always do.
We've done so many things.
So many very legal things.
Except for drowning people.
I've never went that far.
That was, that's the one line I'll never cross.
Wee!
You gonna
let me in?
Knock, knock!
Alright, go to the shipping yard.
What?
But actually I can do it from here, that's good.
Alright, that's easier too.
What?
Who is he?
I don't even know who he is.
You're sitting on it.
And when you get off strong-arming me, huh?
I know you're a cop and I know you're sick.
How would you know?
This is Polis, my Polis.
It's the newest luxury brand.
How would he know?
I don't understand.
I'm...
Undercover!
We're gonna get these guys out of here.
I'm literally undercover.
Woo!
Fast and Furious!
Wait, what do I do from here?
Oh.
There we go.
Because we're in the Fast and Furious movie.
That's why it explode when the tire is shot.
Come on, fuckers!
It's okay.
He won't die.
Wait, we put Nas in the truck?
Where is the truck?
Wait, does he die?
Give me a sec.
I'm testing Ethereum.
Where's the truck?
Oh, is it this one?
There you go.
Okay, there you go.
Go in the trunk.
Go in here.
Oh, I said, I don't said trunk.
Get in here.
He did it.
He successfully micro-dosed down bullets.
And he has gain in unity.
I'm just gonna go straight.
Get rid of him.
rid of the 18k?
Oh, that was like 18k carrot gold?
Wait, actually...
There we go.
You know what?
This is how I'm gonna get rid of it.
Don't worry.
There we go.
We did it.
You only have yourself to play.
It's like, why chase?
We did it.
Alright.
There we go.
It was just that easy.
I was like, why am I driving?
Why am I making this harder for myself?
Inspector?
I have one of your informants in the trunk of my car.
What yeah, he needs to disappear right now.
So either you make him disappear or I will bring him over All right We gotta take him to the undercover HQ I was like, why why am I why am I running away?
I have a gun Like what's the point
There you I'll go this way.
Oh shit.
Oh Oh, hello.
You're supposed to be on the left side of the road?
All right, let's say
Come on, we're gonna take you to a nice place and you'll be gone for it.
You'll disappear forever Disappear
There we go Did we stop?
Let me out of here I fucking shit myself What?
That's so hot.
It's not as threatening when he said he shit himself.
That's all I'm gonna say.
It's very less threatening.
I'll take care of it.
Where he's going, he won't be in a position to tell anyone.
Hey, I can hear you.
What the fuck are you doing out there?
Open the fucking truck.
Hey, show the lady some respect.
I like how he like started threatening us.
He like said he like shit himself and then started threatening us.
I'm like Bro, oh, no you done Yeah
I'm yum yum yum yum.
I'm so hungry.
Oh wait.
I have another mission inside Yeah, that's my other mission Yeah, he's not very smart is I Wait, I have something for you What is it?
Dead triads, six of them in the past few months All found by the water All sliced open What do the investigators think?
I knew it, the water, the ocean murderer I bet the paramedic was included in that murder, right?
This is why I'm coming to you We just found three new bodies under the Three new bodies?
Get down there and take a look around See guys, I told you Uniform officers on the scene one of them is from your crew what you positive keep your head on straight officer told you it wasn't me your eyes open there's actually an ocean murderer it's like the zo it's an ocean killer it's just like the zodiac killer
all right we go this way ocean man yeah they call him the ocean man before he kills you he starts singing ocean man ocean man
all right let's grab my favorite car take me by the hand ocean man no no no no no no no no no no no killer oh let's get the final kill oh it's hard to decide which one do i want to catch a serial killer or and like save save the world from the ocean man or do i do whatever the final kill is
all right what is this
mrs chew oh shit Oh
Guys Dog eyes did it Is that what Johnny told you?
Oh my god, he's cooked
oh my god we had lunch and now we're gonna make dinner guys that's a piece of finger on the table you think red eyes is okay you oh my god she's cooking she's not done she's so hungry
She's still hungry.
Yeah, I mean, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Auntie's Tatsu Bao tastes different today.
Auntie, why does this Tatsu Bao taste a little crunchier than normal?
Y'all, guys, it's actually cooked right now.
All right, this would be the last mission for today.
All right.
Don't worry.
We're just going to be making some dog food very soon, guys.
I can't believe Auntie is expanding her business to dog food, guys.
Wow.
All right.
Search for dog, guys.
We're at official police.
Police.
Maybe it's police.
Co-Ice, the L is silent.
Oh,
he knows.
He was jealous because Winston got a hot wife.
This is a good chase music.
Not gonna lie.
Whoa!
Don't worry.
Don't worry, I'm coming over.
I feel like I'm on a cruise right now.
In the 80s.
Jeez.
Oh my god.
Wait, is that my sister?
That's my sister, you fucker!
That's it.
I'm going to eat one of Anki's dog food after all.
Oh my god.
Dog ass will now be dad's next meal.
even a super chat thank you oh shit oh shit guys don't don't text and drive don't don't text and drive oh my I did too many texting while driving okay this boat is fucking slow as hell this is a slow-ass boat when he got off his boat what I'm at Aberdeen.
It's nice of him to wait for me, you know?
Thank God he was like, where did he go?
Like, this ain't, it's not as exciting when he's not here yet.
Thank God.
Thank God he waited for me.
That's it.
I'm getting, I'm over.
I'm coming over.
Wait.
Oh, shit!
Oh, my God, he's grappling!
That's it.
Alright.
Okay.
I like how he's watching his men do it.
Instead of running away to safety, it's time to swim with the fishes!
Hey, can you help me find Mimo?
Oh!
Oh No Okay, we're gonna we gotta get the small guys first Hey, buddy.
I hope you know how to swim
All right, wait give me a say I'm gonna slap you with a fish now That's right you're scared.
Oh my god He actually tripped he's like oh Holy shit, not the fish!
Okay.
I will slap you with my fish.
My fish!
He just took my fish!
I will slap you with a fish!
Holy shit, this guy is fucking built!
Like, how the fuck...
That's it.
I'm mad now.
I'm mad!
Wait, how do I...
Oh, open.
What do I do?
Excuse me.
Oh, shit.
Excuse me, I'm trying to...
I am trying to slap someone with a...
fish right now?
Oh, there we go.
There we go.
All right, I need more fish.
You can't deny the fish.
Holy shit, how many are there?
All right, one by one, guys.
One by one.
That's all the AI can take.
Wait, what is that?
It's electrifying.
Oh my god.
even know what that oh that's a swordfish that's you sorry i can't do it one life do you play dead by daylight let's get someone's got oh my lord get hooked there we go all right your turn it's friday you know what that means trash day he stopped no he's like oh my god i can't believe she did that i'm ready for the sequel finding dory oh yay fish yay
you've done some bad things sammy what did you call me huh nobody called me Oh my god, did I just phase through that?
Wait, he ran away because she was like, I knew if I talk more about fucking his sister, he's gonna snap.
You can't take this stuff personally, way.
It was business.
You know what I'm saying?
The plot twist was that I was a ghost all along.
Not to me, it wasn't.
If you don't like it, you take it up with bigs.
Lee he's the one we need the pussy I was doing my job oh fuck man is this what this is all about yeah and Winston and Peggy fuck you're coming with me with the police in the back shit man and I'll make sure that big smiley cut you in on one of the side business maybe the fucking whole damn thing I mean hey we can be generous okay yeah he's gonna be the future Just behind me,
huh?
Yeah, we're tight like motherfucking brothers.
Me and Winston, we were tight too.
Get him, get him now.
Wait, I gotta escape.
That's right.
Get snacked!
Oh!
Snack!
Oh no, okay, wait.
That's right.
I'm the killer.
I'm Freddy and five nights at Freddy's.
Wait, no, it's golden.
Oh shit.
I'm trying to think of one-liners.
It's been a while.
No one's gonna save you from golden Freddy.
The hook of 87.
Guys, it's obvious I don't play Dead by Daylight.
It's literally just tag.
It's just tag.
Dead by Daylight is just tagged.
Yes!
If you think that's bad.
Alright, dodge.
Like, I feel like...
Okay, ball punch.
Are you ready to get...
Get shanked?
This is London, but acting the ocean.
Ocean man!
But there's two of them Where's the next trash can?
Oh, there it is That's right I'll tell you a little secret I'm actually the ocean killer Ocean man But No
No way!
He can't tell that...
He can't... Dead man can't tell tales.
Alright, I'll get this guy.
Oh shit.
Okay, I actually have to just do counters.
I'm so low HP right now.
Oh shit!
What?!
There's still HP there!
Draw him, not tell, no tales.
Oh my god.
No, not again.
Ocean man.
Bye.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Da, no, no.
Ocean man.
Wait, actually, I have an idea.
Okay.
I think this bot is already demonetized anyway, so it's fine.
I...
I'm pretty sure.
I'm pretty sure this bot is already demonetized.
Oh shit.
Ocean man.
Wait, you guys can't hear it?
Give me a sec.
Like Nance.
Ocean man.
Last time by the sand.
But not not not.
Ocean man.
Ocean man Oh my god, oh my god, I'm literally getting fucked up by these guys These guys are so tanky Look at them go What the fuck Ocean man Ocean man Ocean man Ocean man
Ocean man
Ocean man Ocean man Ocean man Ocean man Ocean man Ocean man Don Don Ocean man Ocean man
How is this fight still going on?
The song has ended.
How...
How dinky are they?
The song has ended and I'm still fighting them.
There we go!
That's the song I play before the ocean man gets you.
Alright, it's your turn.
There we go.
Come on.
There we go, get out of here.
The ocean man strikes again.
Oh, wait, what the fuck?
Get out.
That's right.
Get your arm out of here.
The ocean punch.
Alright, we gotta make sure I don't accidentally it.
Alright, if the VOD is got...
I'm sorry.
That's okay.
Means I could, I will, if the, if the bond gets striked where it gets blocked, this entire, this entire fight is gone.
This, this, we just lose this, it'll just, this entire fight just gets deleted.
So weird.
We mean so long goes.
Oh shit, oops, sorry.
The wedding happened like yesterday.
What do you mean?
Oh, oops.
Sorry.
Is he dead?
He's still alive.
Okay.
Look, they just said bring him alive, okay?
They didn't say how alive he has to be.
They never said how alive.
Where are we going?
To the restaurant.
Oh, wait.
I'm not the driver.
Thank God.
Can I change the radio?
We're bringing him to Mrs. Chu.
She has something she wants to tell him.
Mrs. Chu.
Alright.
Yeah.
What a lovely drive.
What a lovely What a lovely quiet drive where no murder happened Put it on softly the ocean that played softly as we drive the misses I am the passenger.
Oh, wait, it's time to shoot.
God damn it God damn it.
It's time to shoot Can't have nothing
Oh, nice
easy.
That's a card.
Okay, that's nice.
The card exploded itself.
There you go.
Oh yeah, my card's not okay.
I think I got shot a little too much.
What the fuck?
That motorcycle just spawned in front of me.
This is the perfect car chase on.
Hallelujah.
Oh my god!
Is my car okay?
There you go.
There's still one more behind.
I think I got it.
Let's got shoot at the general director.
Reloading!
There you go.
There's no way I can reach all the- is that- are these guys also part of it?
Can't tell.
There you go.
There's still one more car.
Okay, there's still another car.
Holy shit, how far has Mrs. Shoes been?
There you go.
Oh, we're here.
We'll see.
Yay!
Some good driving there.
Thanks, man.
We did it.
All right.
Do you think he's okay?
Surely the bullets.
Did not hit the trunk, right?
Yeah, he's fine.
Your people are really bad shots.
I don't understand how they did not hit the trunk.
Sit down and shut the fuck up.
Jesus, I haven't been here in fucking years.
Sammy, I've waited on you while you're in the kitchen.
You can see?
I'll leave my blood in the living.
You don't like it, right?
It's cool, Mrs. Choo.
I already ate.
Oh my God, Jesus.
Hey, what the fuck are you doing?
Oh my god, it's his ear!
Oh my god!
He's feeding his Johnny red eyes!
A red face!
A red face?
A friend of Johnny.
A little shoo-zai?
He's not even calling him red face.
He just says he's a rat in general.
A little shoo-j- Wait, if you have a problem with me, then let's sort it out ourselves.
A little shoo-zai?
It's just rap boy
Well, I can't wait to try mrs. Chow's new special new special today.
Do you guys hear?
Chad new special tells you about
Wow mrs. Chow your broth today is extra meat is extra meaty Oh
Yay, more trauma, yes, for a way, let's go.
Uncle Poe wants to see you.
Come to the hospital.
Big smiley, Toochin, and Auntie Yang are waiting.
All right.
All right, I'm going to call it.
I think that's a good place to call it.
I'm just like, what the fuck just happened?
I just saw it.
I just...
Oh my god, oh no, he is definitely filled with PTSD right now.
He ain't looking too good, guys.
I think he's too deep and undercover guys
That that's so that's the but that's why it makes you a whole man because it's made of men I get it now.
Oh my god.
It all came.
It's a circle.
It all came back to the tasu bow That's why it makes you a whole man
it makes sense now mrs. Chu's pork buns are all manned baby you are what you eat and yes I hope you guys had a great time watching today I always have a great time streaming for all of you guys um we had a great adventure with way think he's feeling so great but we had a good time he might have trauma ptsd for the rest of his life but that's okay we had a good time um i hope you guys had a fun time on watching with me um i'm gonna head off now i got lots of work backlog to do because i was i've sadly been i've relapsed into a rival's rank addiction also for those who watched the uh stream on twitch i think it was story about the guy that I knew was hacking his account actually got banned I like you know after you guys were like yeah you should have reported I was like you know what I should have so then I went and like reported him and I got the message being like oh yeah that guy's been banned I was like I knew it I knew it was them I so he actually got banned at like afterwards so
I'm like I knew it vindication I knew it was those two hey guys as always everybody stay hydrated posture move around to get that blood flowing and if you suffer me head to bed because you deserve it i'll see you guys next time everybody bye guys bye